plex uh the those clashes occurring
outside in the very spot as we've been
discussing with greg milan there where
in two weeks time precisely
president-elect
joe biden will become president biden
um so a lot going on there also hearing
that
the current vice president mike pence
who presides
over those senatorial meetings presides
over that
chamber has been taken to a place of
safety well uh we're trying to get more
from the ground
right by those demonstrators but as you
can understand communications are
fairly difficult and chaotic at the
moment so um let's get more who's got a
loftier view much as we have more from
our washington correspondent greg
milam there and um greg so we're hearing
it's
it's still all locked down so whatever
happens it's going to
delay this process
yeah i mean it's a process that was
already going to go probably into
tomorrow anyway so i don't think it's
it's done much to change that but
it's it's more the image that this sends
of of
a symbol of democracy the us capital
under attack we understand protesters
are breaking glass
in some of the doors on the outside it's
clear people are trying to get in some
may have been
uh successful the police inside the
capital
the u.s capitol police have been handing
out uh masks to to people in the chamber
clearly concerned about the the tear gas
or the prospect of more tear gas needing
to be used
to control any uh any protests i mean we
can see
a large number of of of people on the on
the lawns
around the capital the steps that lead
up to it of course the steps
where the inauguration will take place
in two weeks time uh
they seem to be the focus of a large
number of the the protesters who are
there
uh and as i say a massive police
response that we've been able to witness
from here
we've certainly been able to hear from
here uh heading to those um those
plazas around the capital which would
have been where people would have been
allowed to to protest it was always
planned that
they would march from where donald trump
was speaking outside the white house
today
it was always planned that they would
march here and make their point donald
trump did hint in his speech that he
would come with them
on that march there's no indication that
he that he did do that
but what's what's what wasn't expected
and what seems to have taken the
authorities by surprise
is is so many of the the protesters
getting so close to the capital uh and
maybe some even inside and
the security concerns about that because
there is real anger amongst those
protesters and the police were aware of
that
the ability to get inside and perhaps
cause damage or some security threat to
those who are carrying out that uh that
that duty of certifying the
the process is a is a real concern and
that's why we've seen this huge response
to these images of pretty violent
clashes between
the police and some of these supporters
of donald trump who've marched up here
some of the the march encouraged by the
president for for days he's been telling
people
to come and express their views in
washington uh
and that is what a number of people have
done most of them
uh perfectly peacefully but uh some not
as is clear
wow and greg just the subject we were
discussing just the overall effect on
the republican party so it's lost
control it appears
of the senate today lost the presidency
of course
uh lost the house of representatives
control of that a couple of years back
it is it fracturing because we've
discussed mike pence the vice
president there saying that he he
wouldn't obey the president do what he
wanted uh
the majority leader mitch mcconnell
saying that that it would be
unprecedented in american history for
congress to overrule the voters
is it fracturing
i think there's an interesting story
coming out of georgia of course where it
seems the democrats have taken those
those two senate seats from republicans
remarkable in itself but
significant in that it will give
democrats control of the the senate the
upper chamber in congress
they already have control of the of the
lower chamber the house of
representatives
but what was striking about that
election in the minds of many
republicans was that every time donald
trump talked about the election being
rigged
it put off republican voters who thought
to themselves well why would i go and
take part in another election if
it's just going to be rigged and there's
real anger amongst republicans in
georgia
that they believe the president has cost
them those two seats
with those with those messages along
with the fact that many republicans
felt pretty disillusioned that donald
trump didn't win
uh weren't that motivated to go out and
vote anyway when democrats were able to
motivate and energize
uh younger voters a more diverse
electorate and and
can complete that shift that started in
november when donald trump
when sorry joe biden won uh the state of
georgia
now those two seats in a place so
republican so republican for so long
uh that really significant and of course
the fact that now
uh tying the the senate 50 50 republican
and democrats or 48 democrats and two
independents who vote democrat
which gives uh the democrats control
bearing in mind the
the president of the of the senate is
the is the vice president so a democrat
is very significant even to the point of
who can be appointed by joe biden to his
cabinet today we're hearing who he's
going to appoint as his attorney general
a massively significant
uh role that um he was he needs to
decide on he's chosen it seems merrick
garland the man who barack obama put
forward for the supreme court when he
was president
he knows that those uh those
appointments will now
those those appointments now will breeze
through uh because he has control of the
senate it is hugely significant as much
as his election was in november
okay greg for the time being thank you
very much indeed these are
extraordinary scenes in the seats of
american democracy protests
protesters outside the capitol building
and
inside as well some of them anyway
causing
a lockdown an end of proceedings to
ratify
the presidential election
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
at eight o'clock i'm dermott monahan
this is sky news tonight the top story
the u.s
capitol in lockdown donald trump's
supporters have converged on washington
to try to overturn the election result
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's depth
involved
these are live shots from the heart of
washington now where donald trump's
supporters
have apparently breached security
barricades we're also hearing that vice
president
pence has been taken to a secure
location well tonight we'll have the
very latest delight for you
from washington dc also ahead
1041 more deaths are recorded in the uk
as the prime minister warns there's only
a cautious route out of the coveted
lockdown
why exams are out and teacher assessed
grades are in
for a levels and gcses but this month's
b tech exams
are still on and we hear the warning
from south africa over its young variant
and its potential to blunt the impact of
vaccines
and still going for gold despite the
pandemic we meet the british olympian
who has to believe the gains
will go ahead
[Music]
very good evening to you the u.s capitol
building is in lockdown right now
supporters of president trump have
converged on washington
to try to overturn the election results
from last november security barricades
have apparently been breached outside
the capitol building
police we are told have fired some tear
gas
at protesters and the doors of the
senate chamber
have been closed and locked it was
inside the senate where they were going
to ratify that election result from the
vice president mike pence who presides
over the senate has apparently been
escorted to a secure
location other senators and
congress men and women are apparently
sheltering in their offices the
protesters
are trying to stop congress from
formally approving president-elect joe
biden's
victory back in november's election and
in the last few minutes
uh president trump has tweeted that they
should stay
peaceful of course the president did
address elements of that crowd
earlier at a rally before they some of
them anyway uh
went up the steps of the capitol
building and
the president apparently went back to
the white house but has tweeted that
any protest should stay peaceful let's
get the latest let's get you
up to speed from the scene skies
washington correspondent greg milam
is there and greg what i want you to do
first of all is is just give us the
sequence
of events both inside the
capitol building and uh what has
happened with those
crowds there how they got there why
they're there
yeah and you can you can see those
crowds still on the steps of the uh the
us capital pretty unprecedented
i've got to say for those who've watched
what goes on in washington over many
years i think this is this is quite
astonishing what we're seeing inside and
outside of the
the capital but yeah it all started
earlier with many of these people
who were down at a rally down near the
white house
the other end of the national mall
donald trump there giving a
giving a speech again repeating his
claims that the election had been stolen
from him
laying out in an hour-long speech what
he said was the evidence much of which
we've heard before and has been
dismissed by the courts of course but
giving that speech and again
encouraging those uh protesters to
continue
uh with their protest now when he
finished uh and in fact during that
speech he said he would be with them on
this
uh they they began this march as was
always planned
up to the capitol building the building
you're seeing there they began that
march
and by the time they got here these
first flashes of violence it appears
many of those protesters were intent on
on getting inside the capitol building
because inside of there was this this
joint session of the the house of
representatives and the senate the two
chambers
which was convened to formally certify
the the result of
november's presidential election and
this tension that existed for the vice
president mike pence
and throughout donald trump's speech he
continued to put pressure on mike pence
to do something in that certification
process to overturn the election now
according to the constitution he can't
do that no one expected that mike pence
really would do that but donald trump
continued to pile the pressure on
his vice president and certainly ramped
up the crowd i think
to demand more of the vice president in
this what is a ceremonial role where
that hearing began
even before mike pence has started
speaking he'd released a text of a
letter that he sent to members of
congress
in which he said he wanted people to air
their protests
members of congress to to air their
concerns about electoral fraud
for that to be debated but said that he
didn't constitutionally
have the right to overturn the election
to do anything other than just
accept these votes and move on so at
some point mike pence will announce that
joe biden has been elected
president kamala harris elected vice
president it's a ceremonial moment we've
never taken any
notice really of it in previous years uh
that will happen at some point but
currently that hearing is uh suspended
because of a concern
about the safety of those inside it's
reported that some
of these protesters have managed to
breach the the doors of the uh
of the the capitol building uh the
building itself has been locked down
many of the members of congress inside
vote a shelter in place uh concerns
about about tear gas and concerns about
people get in
getting in who are clearly very angry
the president has tweeted that they
should stay peaceful they should respect
law and order they should respect law
enforcement who are trying to protect
that building it came a little late
because i think these the anger boiled
over long before that uh that tweet came
and you can you can see the scene
there and we've seen images from inside
of people uh continuing that that
protest
uh and clearly the anger is very real
amongst donald trump's uh supporters
most of them completely peaceful i've
got to say and
we're standing here watching many of
them filtering their way out of
washington
but uh but a hard core of them uh
remaining to make these points
and as we've seen in in some previous
protests in washington
in recent months since november they
have boiled over
generally those those clashes have been
against
uh some of those counter protesters
those from the other side of the
political spectrum here this one
is largely a clash with the capitol
police who protect this building
but also a clash with democracy itself
if you like this is where
a democratic process is going on and
they are many of them trying to storm
that building to put a stop to it
and greg i want to ask you about that
democratic process of course in normal
times members of the public are allowed
in to
watch proceedings as much as they are in
the house of commons is that still the
case under the
covid restrictions and might that be the
way that uh some
people if they are might that be the way
that some of the protesters got it
[Music]
i don't know if the public is allowed in
at the moment there are certainly
restrictions on how many members of
congress are allowed to be in the
chamber at any one time so i
i feel there wouldn't be a large number
of members of the public
uh inside and i know certainly members
of congress were having to use some of
the public galleries just
so that they could be spaced out away
from the away from the chamber
we're hearing from some of those inside
the house chamber that they have now
been evacuated they've been taken to one
of the office buildings
uh around the capital there are numerous
ones on all sides
you can see in that that picture there
lots of those members wearing gas masks
were being told as they move through the
buildings
calling family members telling them
they're okay uh
that there's a real um a real concern
for those inside about their own
uh safety uh at a time like this
and and you can hear the sirens
reverberating around
the around the capital and and
the effort to get law enforcement there
to try to bring this under control
because i think it took them by surprise
i think they always knew there was going
to be an angry and loud protest
and a large number of people but the the
level of both of those things seems to
have taken them by surprise
okay uh greg stay with us but i want to
get some reaction now from the united
states good distance away though
uh from uh california i'm joined now by
professor
nate pursley from stanford law school
there and uh
very good to talk to you professor
personally and i did
want to start uh talking and using your
legal expertise
first of all but um just tell me
no doubt you're watching these scenes as
an american as a citizen what do you
make of what you're witnessing
well this is a chilling scene it's an
unprecedented scene
at a time when congress was basically
just
ratifying the votes of the american
people
you have a mob that's descended on the
capitol
uh to try to stop that process um to try
to try to stop american democracy from
happening
uh this has never happened uh this whole
proceeding
in challenging the election results this
has never happened before
uh and certainly you've never had the
leader of the country
uh trying to interrupt the process of
democracy in elections like we've seen
in the last two months
and this is the extraordinary thing
though isn't it of course the
the president's is not there he uh spoke
to that crowd we
understand he's gone back to the white
house where he has tweeted for the
protests
to remain peaceful he hasn't actually
asked them to disperse
and this is the the heart the epicenter
of american democracy
it is i mean just so your viewers
understand they have breached the
capital they are
in the ceremonial room there um they
they have gone past the metal detectors
that ordinarily would prevent people
from getting into the
uh house so we have no idea uh sort of
what they're bringing in with them and
so it is an unprecedented situation
um um we've never seen this before you i
mean you can't
get into the capital uh you know with
metal objects and the like in normal
circumstances let alone covet
circumstances let alone
on the day that they're certifying the
election results so um
this is you know really just a disaster
that we're seeing
um uh happen before us now just to be
clear
joe biden will be certified as the
president of the united states he will
take
office on january 20th this is um
a black mark on the history of the
united states and on our democracy but
we will
um have a new president on january 20th
and i just wanted to ask you i mean just
to explain to the british audience about
this
this certification process we've never
really noticed it in this country
very much before i'm sure many in the
united states haven't really it's
normally a rubber stamping
operation but because of these
extraordinary circumstances it has
loomed large
just give me your sense of what the
president thought he might be able
to achieve it involved the vice
president who seems to have peeled away
from him now but just
just explain i suppose in layperson's
terms
what he thought he might be able to get
his supporters to do
so generally speaking this process of
voting on the slates of electors or or
sort of
ratifying them takes maybe a half an
hour maybe 45 minutes where you just
read the names of the states and then
you say all right these
electors go for joe biden these electors
go for donald trump
uh it is it's such a non-event that
there are some
members of the senate who don't even
remember it happening before
uh but according to the constitutional
legal machinery that is out there
particularly a law that was passed in
1887. um there is the opportunity
for members of congress to object to
slates of electors
and that was what was happening before
the protests
happened here when the state of
arizona's name was
raised a member of congress member of
the house of representatives a member of
the senate
uh objected and so they they left
that the house and then senate are
together for the reading of the
electoral votes
they then separate in order to debate
the objections
that was what was happening in the house
and senate was that they were debating
the objections and then that debate was
stopped abruptly when the protesters
breached the
um the grounds um as you're saying you
know this is normally a ceremonial
process
what in the in the last few weeks what
president trump has been pushing
is for um vice president pence who
presides over the joint session
to take an extraordinary role and to
somehow
unilaterally tilt the process in a way
that the um
that for example an electors of
electoral slave from one state might not
get counted
uh but as you said earlier today uh
right before he entered the chamber he
issued a letter saying look i don't have
the power to do this
um and all i am doing is going to
facilitate the debate over the
objections
and then uh the different leaders of the
senate and the house
will then um vote on the uh objections
right the the whole bodies will
um i do want to say one bright spot that
had happened
before the protesters uh took the the
building is that senator mitchell
mcconnell the majority leader
uh on the senate gave an impassioned uh
speech
defending the electoral result and
trying to pull us back from the brink we
can see it was not
successful at least by measures of the
crowds that are outside and now inside
uh but you did have a significant number
of republicans who were trying to
beat back this effort to undermine the
democracy
and what might flow from this what might
the repercussions be i mean this might
sound a ridiculous question but it is
coming from
some democratic congress
congressional uh leaders uh members of
the house of representatives
could could the president be impeached
again he's only got two weeks
to run of course he was impeached and
acquitted this time last year
could that process happen again is that
at all possible
in theory it could happen but it's not
going to happen uh there wouldn't be the
votes in the senate probably for it to
um for him to be impeached and removed
um i think that you know more likely
what
what will happen is that a greater share
of republicans will see
the danger of the path that they have
been treading here and that then he will
go slowly into that good night i think
that's the that's the hope
we are in for two more weeks of what
could be unprecedented
behavior um this process of dealing with
the objectors
like i said usually takes a half an hour
or so of um
with the electoral slates my guess is it
will extend
into tomorrow um but they the
republicans were planning to object to
arizona georgia and pennsylvania's
electors
that uh one of the things we'll see is
whether some of the wind has been taken
out of their cells by
by what we're seeing on the capitol
grounds now so that maybe they will dial
this back
and not object to as many states as they
were planning to
okay professor personally really good
talking to you thank you very much
indeed for your expertise and all that
background
really good talking to you nate
personally there from stanford law
school
well uh sky sally lockwood is on the
ground there
somewhere joining us on the phone
amongst those protesters and
straight questions sally for you i know
it might be difficult hearing me so
just describe what is happening
one of the moments um i'm very close
to uh the entrance to one of the
entrances to the capitol building
and it is surrounded by hundreds
of protesters carrying uh
signs that say stop fraud some are
banging on the windows and the door
uh and the sides of the capitol building
we are
hearing that the capitol building has
been breached and that some of those
protesters have made it
inside it's not clear if they're still
inside or if they've been removed
but certainly it's a very volatile
situation down here
uh these protesters of which there are
thousands i should say
at hundreds right up at the capitals
entrance but
thousands more in the surrounding area
about capitol hill who
marched here from that rally that we saw
where donald trump addressed
his supporters a few hours ago and he
urged them to take part in this march to
protest the election results
and there is a lot of criticism that he
has encouraged this he's incited this
this unrest this uh violent behavior and
for members of the citizens of america
the united states to clash with law
enforcement indeed
when we were walking up pennsylvania
avenue with
the protesters on that march some of
them surrounded police vehicles who were
trying to head for the capitol building
in response to what was going on
and there's a lot of anger here a lot of
people who feel
that somehow there's been some
wrongdoing they wanted to halt
what was happening here in congress
today and of course
a very real threat to members of
congress who we understand have been
evacuated in
uh using underground tunnels uh vice
president mike pence has been taken to a
safe location and there was a lot of
anger towards mike pence
in that march towards capitol hill
a lot of people shouting angry remarks
about
vice president and indeed donald trump
tweeting as well that he's
the courage to do what was needed but as
we know his role today was a ceremonial
role
but the mis-education and the
misinformation that donald trump
has been peddling uh means that people
here feel that
there's been some doing and he hasn't
carried out his duty
uh we do understand as well that we are
going to be hearing from
president-elect joe biden very surely he
was due to be speaking on the economy
today in wilmington well
we don't expect that to happen uh we
definitely hear
expect to be hearing from him about the
situation which is unfolding
on capitol hill okay sally stay with us
but you mentioned there um the president
addressing
that crowd earlier in the day let's just
have a
a bit of a listen to some of what
president trump said
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved
states want to revoke the states
got defrauded they were given false
information
they voted on it now they want to
recertify they want it back
all vice president pence has to do is
send it back to the states
to recertify and we become
president and you are the happiest
people
well the president then left that rally
there had been
suggestions that he was going to stay
with the crowds as they then moved
towards the steps
of the capitol building but we
understand he returned to the white
house from where he
tweeted about an hour ago this please
support our
capital police and law enforcement
they are truly on the side of our
country
stay peaceful didn't tell them to
disperse but
told them to stay peaceful and uh from
what you're
seeing sally i mean from what we're
seeing gotta gotta be honest here from
what we're seeing they're milling around
but
it looks chaotic but peaceful
yes it's still largely peaceful uh the
majority of people here
aren't being violent but there are some
who are now undertaking activities that
certainly
would be described as otherwise i'm
actually watching a couple of people
scale the walls of the capital
at the moment using some sort of rope
climbing up
and also i should say dermot there are
people here
in body armor with helmets on uh you
know
people who come to a peaceful protest
dressed in body armor
uh aren't necessarily expecting it to be
peaceful or
perhaps even to be peaceful themselves
there's been a lot of people
today that i've spoken to in ballistic
type
vest and approaching them i've asked a
few of them if they wanted to do an
interview
and they don't actually want to talk to
me on camera
or answer questions about why they're
dressed the way they're dressed
but certainly uh there are extremist
groups on both sides i should say
uh who are known for being violent uh
at events like this and we're hearing
reports as well
that there have been some injuries and
an unconfirmed report
of someone being shot in the capitol
building area but we haven't had that
confirmed that is an
unconfirmed report at the moment dermot
yeah okay unconfirmed and uh any sense
sally i know how difficult this is maybe
we're in a better place to assess it
ourselves just from the television shots
certainly at the rally any sense of how
large it was
well there were thousands there
certainly um
i couldn't begin to estimate an exact
number but to give you an idea the
the area where the rally was being held
in front of the white house
in the park area there that was that was
full and it
the crowd stretched back pretty much to
at the washington
monument so it was a really really big
crowd and
have it doesn't feel like it's dispersed
either
it feels like the majority of those
people have made their way down to
the capitol building i should say that
before we went into
that rally uh earlier there was intense
security screening
uh and it was announced several times to
the press that
anyone with a gas mask would not be
allowed in
with that equipment and that we were to
uh find somewhere else to leave it
uh now we understand that tear gas has
already been fired here
uh in the capital building in response
to those protesters who clashed with
police and
of course reports as well that gas masks
have been given
to members of congress after tear gas
was fired so while they may have not
asked us to take in guest mods today
certainly when you look at the sort of
equipment that some of the protesters
have got here
and the protective equipment these
ballistic
proof vests certainly some people have
come here prepared
for violence and sally of course these
events taking place
at the very spot where in two weeks time
president trump will be former president
trump and president-elect biden
becomes a sitting president of the
united states
they must be worried the the law
enforcement the security officials that
have to try to keep things peaceful that
uh if this crowd turns up again
and of course the thousands upon
thousands of democratic
supporters that is going to be well to
say the least a difficulty
yeah absolutely two weeks today the
inauguration
and what we're looking at at the moment
on capitol hill
are protesters climbing all over the
structures
that have been put up for that
inauguration ceremony
uh it's hard to imagine how we're going
to see a peaceful
inauguration and transition of power
take place in two weeks time
when the incumbent president won't even
acknowledge the election result
uh or concede let alone offer
some conciliatory language to the
incoming president
and assistant at a peaceful transition
of power i should say
in the last hour donald trump has
tweeted to his supporters to
keep it peaceful it does feel a little
bit late for him to be asking them to do
that
after touching them and urging them in
his speech at that rally earlier
to essentially march upon capitol hill
a stolen election and of course angering
people making them feel that they can't
trust the damage democratic system
in this country
okay sally i don't know if you're still
with us um
seemed to be something happening there
if you are
uh can you just confirm you asked
whether sally if not i'll update our
viewers and listeners on the situation
as we understand it
i'm still with you okay great and i can
hear the siren behind you i i know just
how difficult
it is to communicate in those
circumstances but sally you mentioned
there the reluctance of members of the
crowd to talk to you
as journalists i'm sure we all want to
ask one
central question and i'm i don't know if
you got any kind of response to this and
it is
what do you expect to happen here do you
really expect that
the results of that presidential
election to be
to be overturned 150 million americans
voted expressed their preference in that
election
did you get any any sense of what they
wanted to see happen
well the common answer from many of the
people that i spoke to earlier was that
mike pence was going to save the day
and of course that was the message that
donald trump was peddling was that
mike pence if i tried as president
needed to do the right thing today
he was caught in a very very difficult
corner
trying to remain the trump loyalist that
he is but also
carry out his constitutional duty which
was to certify this vote today it wasn't
congress's role to question it
that had already been verified and
confirmed at state level the election
results
this is just a ceremonial proceeding
that
vice president pence was providing over
today and let's not forget that's
exactly the role that joe biden paid
when he was vice president and certified
the election results
for the incoming president trump uh
by mike pence his hands retired today in
terms of what he could do
and on twitter donald trump turned on
him having
having called on him during his speech
before his supporters to do the right
thing and have courage he then turned on
him
on twitter once he had submitted this
letter to congress
to say that he couldn't unilaterally
reject
votes or count them so
he was caught between a rock and a hard
place if you like and it does feel here
that
those people who were banking on my tent
to save the day today
are now turning on him uh and i'm yet to
hear
the theories of how they feel this
election can be overturned now
but in uh the conversations you did or
didn't have and in previous ones you get
a sense
don't you that uh for those that support
donald trump
to the very end as it seems this
is um they wanted to stay on they wanted
to
have another go perhaps in 2024 of
course he's
only been a one-term president
absolutely they they want him to run
again in 2024 and some
and some people that you speak to here
don't even see him leaving
in two weeks time they still somehow
think that this election can be
overturned such is the wrong doing that
has taken
place and of course donald trump himself
not offering any sort of conciliatory
language or trying to uh appease
this situation and this division in the
country
it's unclear how he's going to make his
exit from the white house in two weeks
time we don't expect him to attend the
inauguration indeed there are rumors he
may even go to
his golf course in scotland but it is
unclear at the moment
how that is all going to play out but
certainly there are still many here who
believe that donald trump won't be going
anywhere in two weeks time
okay sally stay with us i'll let you
catch your breath and uh maybe
reposition yourself uh
maybe get some more information for us
some but uh just want to remind our
viewers and listeners about what's going
on the background to
all this and it's extraordinary events
taking place both
inside and outside that building
you can see the us capital the heart of
american democracy as we have been
telling you inside a senate sitting to
formally ratify the presidential
election
results one which is you heard sally
explaining the president wanted his vice
president
the formerly loyal mike pence as the
president of the of the senate he
presides over its proceedings
uh president trump wanted mike pence to
be involved in trying to
overrule some of the state's election
results something as you heard sally
tell us mike pence says he was
unable to do now at the same time
outside
that building and you can see the the
remnants and it's more than remnants of
it there was a large demonstration
addressed by
president trump telling his supporters
there his ardent supporters the
so-called base
that the fight goes on that uh again
that theory he has that they've been
somehow robbed that the whole electoral
process has been
fraudulent the fight continues he wanted
the senators to say to
overthrow overturn that election results
the presidents
then went back to the white house there
was
some suggestion he may stay with some of
those protesters and perhaps march them
up
the steps of the capitol building that
didn't happen the president uh
returned to the white house and tweeted
that the demonstrations
should remain peaceful that they should
cooperate with
law enforcement but he has not told them
to disperse
and the upshot is we can see the scenes
outside and we are getting reports
of what has happened inside protesters
either got in to the capitol building or
some of them perhaps were already
in there and have disrupted proceedings
senators and representatives have
been put into lockdown we understand
that vice president pence has been taken
to a secure location and
other representatives and senators are
sheltering in place
in their offices and as i say
proceedings
suspended for the time being we have not
got
any other shots obviously inside the
building for you also hearing from the
washington dc authorities from the mayor
of
d.c that they will impose a curfew from
6 p.m this evening that's a
washington time so in about what
just under three hours time but
meanwhile those
thousands of people gathered on the
steps of the capital building
well uh let's try to return to sally
lockwood now
and uh sally i don't know if you've been
able to to change your position or
indeed uh find
out any any more information uh that's
about the bones of it though
um proceeding suspended inside the
capitol building and this
large crowd gathered outside they're not
going anywhere
no it feels like it's only getting
bigger actually i should say there's
been
an emergency alert uh issued
t-wide which we've all received on our
phones
uh and a curfew has now been called
tonight here in washington dc from 6 p.m
by dc's mayor until 6 o'clock tomorrow
morning
uh they're obviously trying to get a
handle on the growing number of people
that have surrounded the capital
building here
uh so from 6pm anyone who isn't a
healthcare worker an essential worker
will have to go home and that's
obviously
in a bid to try and help out law
enforcement who we understand
are struggling we've seen law
enforcement and police vehicles
surrounded by crowds of protesters
ourselves we understand the national
guard is on the way
uh washington dc's mayor called in the
national guard
in anticipation of see the themes that
we are witnessing at the moment let me
just
speak to someone who's nearby who's just
been up
in the stick of the action where the
pepper spray and the tear gas has been
fired
and hopefully you'll be able to hear him
can i just ask him
sean um so what were you seeing up there
by the capitol building
so i was not inside the capitol building
but i was seeing some tear gas being
shot and people trying to break in and
people coming out and i talked to a lot
of people who said that they got inside
the building
and then the cops cleared them out after
they got inside and they got pepper
sprayed and
you know thrown out and people are
trying to get in again and there's just
a lot of back and forth between riot
police and protesters
and are there still people inside there
now that you can see uh i
i was not inside i just know what i
heard from the people coming out with
the tear
you know the tear gas all over their
face so
and do you feel that this sort of scene
is helpful
what point are they trying to make here
i think
i think a lot of i think a lot of people
are
trying to intimidate the congress but
they're they're very angry because
congress
is very corrupt and they're trying to
scare them in a lot of ways into
complying because like uh it's like a
show of power like oh there's a shitload
of us that care and are willing to do
something if you get a person
i apologize i apologize for any bad
language there
so you'll get a sense that um it is
quite chaotic here still
uh and there are people still behaving
fairly violently from what we can see
pushing against
uh the entrance uh to congress but of
course that
m curfew has been called by washington
dc's mayor tonight and we'll
get that works if that helps disperse
some of the crowd here
sally uh yeah um we are just i'm just
monitoring um
information as it comes in here to us on
the newswire
services and uh we are getting
unconfirmed reports about
um gun fire of some
description and you when we were talking
earlier that that's that's something
you've heard and certainly
uh tear gas being used as well uh
any evidence of that well certainly from
some of the people i've spoken to here
tear gas
and pepper spray is something that they
have been fired by police here
we are also hearing reports uh
that one person was shot by a member of
law enforcement
we don't have any other details at this
stage we don't know
what law enforcement officer fired the
shot all the circumstances
of the shootings but we will try to find
out more information
on that now yeah and uh while you were
talking
there to that uh protester and we we saw
some shots here of some pretty heavily
armed
police perhaps or or national guard and
and that's what you're hearing there are
also
unconfirmed reports that i'm monitoring
here saying that uh 200 state troopers
from the state of
virginia are being sent to washington
d.c
yeah i can believe that there are more
than 300 uh members of the national
guard
were called in ahead of these protests
of course a significant police presence
we've seen the wyatt police uh in the
grounds of the capitol building
uh it's unclear what their next move
will be but no doubt uh
the department will be coordinating how
to deal with this unfolding situation
this evening
with of course at 60 and turks who
intended to try
to bring it to some sort of conclusion
we'll see if that happens and sally
let's just continue that discussion
about the effect i mean
dealing obviously with the scenes in
front of us but
um the effect that that will be having
on on many
senior republicans we mentioned mike
pence the vice president who
the president had hoped would support
him on the floor of the senate
in that attempt to get the election
result overturned but
also on the floor of the senate another
incredibly powerful republican now
the majority leader for the time being
anyway
mitch mcconnell um for quite a while now
he's
he's made it clear that uh the president
has lost and must accept it
yes that's right mitch mcconnell for
some time now uh
has acknowledged joe barton's victory
and
certainly senior members of congress
such as mitch mcconnell opposed this
move
by republican senators and more than a
hundred republican house representatives
who plan to object to this certification
of the election results here in congress
today and that has really
riled up donald trump supporters who
feel
there's been some wrong doing here that
this election has been
stolen in some way by widespread
fraud even though senior republican
election officials
have come forward most recently of
course in georgia the secretary of state
for georgia
very publicly uh this week saying
that the data doesn't match donald trump
allegations but that move by
uh members of uh the senate and that
their house
those republicans uh trying to object
to this vote has only added
to the sense of wrongdoing here in
supporting
donald trump's lives that there has been
widespread forward and this election has
been stolen
extraordinary scenes uh sally uh also uh
hearing that several people
have been treated for injuries from
washington dc
uh fire service and emergency services
saying
several people have been treated for
injury injuries and that unconfirmed i
must stress that report of a person
who has been shot at the u.s capitol
several law enforcement officials saying
one person
has been shot inside the capitol
building by a member of law
enforcement that is not i must stress
not
confirmed but that is the thinking and
uh
the thinking being that um several
people
we don't know how many got into the
building and disrupted proceedings
yes that's right i'm hearing uh an
unconfirmed report from the american
media at the moment that the person
being treated for gunshot wounds
is a woman and that she is in a critical
condition
after being shot in the chest on the
capital
grounds now that is according to
american sources speaking
to the american media we have not had
that concerned ourselves
like of course we do know that one
person has
been shot here today by law enforcement
in this melee that we are witnessing
unfold around the capitol ground
of course there were members of congress
in the capitol building
when this crowd throughout began to
surround it and breached
the building now we understand that they
were absolutely stunned by this they
were given face masks
to protect them from tear gas that was
fired against the protesters
uh and amid the the chaos they were also
evacuated using
underground tunnels from the capitol
building
it certainly uh wouldn't be possible to
evacuate
and unfaithfully above ground at the
moment
from what we're seeing here
okay sally for the time being thank you
very much indeed that's sally lockwood
down there outside the capitol building
in washington dc
with and amongst those protesters i want
to get some reaction now
from jd gordon former senior national
security and foreign policy
adviser to donald trump and former
pentagon spokesman during the george w
bush administration
uh very good to talk to you jd gordon
just give me your
reaction to what you're seeing outside
the capitol and what we're hearing about
what's going on inside
thanks for having me on the show today
well it's a terrible day for the united
states a shocking day i never thought we
would see
this type of thing in my lifetime i
think
what you're seeing right now is a lot of
people
within the political right are very
frustrated with
what they've seen as as an attack on our
democracy over the past four
years with russiagate for instance um
there were these allegations from the uh
political left
and from some on the right as well that
president trump
and his associates were essentially
russian agents who stole the election
that was of course not true it was the
crime of the century this russia gate
collusion hoax
and then what we saw in these elections
uh this uh last year we've seen
election day turn into election weeks
and election months
uh the rules of the game were changed
throughout the united states due to
coronavirus restrictions etc of course
and so what you had is a record turnout
and tens of millions of people voting by
mail
and so basically what a lot of people
think on the right is that the
the elections were stolen against
president trump and that he was the
rightful winner so what you're seeing is
a backlash right now
uh it's a terrible backlash it's
obviously gone way too far
um but you know i think that when you
keep attacking one political side
eventually would be a backlash well
let's just deal with the facts though as
you mentioned there in the presidential
election unprecedented number of
americans voted
unprecedented numbers of americans voted
for both candidates uh
turned out more for joe biden let's talk
about the president's role in all this i
mean he was out there
just a few hours ago addressing those
crowds he still
believes that he still believes that
this has been stolen
i couldn't judge from your opening
comments there jd gordon whether
you believe he's right in that or
whether he should give up this
forlorn campaign well i
i do believe that he thinks he's the
rightful winner
uh unfortunately the rules of the game
were changed throughout the course of
the year uh
last year um and i think also
one reason he's very reluctant to leave
the white house is because
you have these uh local and state
prosecutors in new york that keep
saying that they're going to prosecute
him for past business dealings and for
his taxes
so why would you want to leave office if
you know you're going to be prosecuted
and possibly sent to prison like what
italy did to serve
silvio berlusconi why would you want to
have that happen
so of course he's fighting as hard as he
can it's tragic
so it's it's really a tragedy from both
sides
i would say a tragedy from people trying
to persecute him for being the president
but just on that i mean that
self-preservation you describe that
attempt at self-preservation that's the
tragic thing isn't it i mean this is
this is a noble cause this is american
democracy
a beacon the americans like to tell
everyone for the rest of the world and
and look at it those scenes they're
chaotic
they are chaotic exactly right so i i
think those uh prosecutors in new york
at the state level
and at the the district level in
manhattan need to take
a look at what they're doing uh they're
causing a person like president trump
who is still the president
he got 75 million votes in the united
states he's still
very popular and look what he's
essentially unleashed today
yeah he doesn't want to be prosecuted
the office i mean yeah you mentioned the
75 million i also mentioned joe biden's
80-plus million
so he won um don't you think though the
president i understand what you're
telling me about um
the prosecutions you think they're the
potential prosecution do you think
they're spurious and
this attempted self-preservation by the
president but the writing
is on the wall it's over he lost
that election american democracy for all
its
faults and twists and turns has acted
once again as it does every four years
and
you and i remember two thousand well you
know the democrats could have been
aggrieved about that given how close
that all was this is what happens in the
democracy and isn't this the bigger
issue that is at stake here and the
president is fundamentally
damaging it he's casting so much doubt
on these processes
yeah that's a true statement look what
happened in georgia
now it appears that the republicans will
lose control of the senate because of
those two
runoff elections in georgia so uh
the united states can fundamentally
change with the white house and democrat
control the senate
and house of representatives both under
democrat control and the democrat
party is not like the party of jfk or
bill clinton
uh the democrats have been very much
radicalized in the past couple of
decades
uh so you're going to see a very
different the united states right now
and a lot of people are
very afraid of that they're afraid of
what's going to happen to free speech
they're afraid of the big money from big
tech and others who are suppressing
the political right so it's a very scary
time in the united states and
unfortunately president trump is
playing right into that as well yeah i
mean he could end this
one imagines right now given how fervent
how ardent supporters they are
of him there they are milling around we
understand some god inside congress i
mean
if they if more of them are god in this
would be a form of mob rule
the president can end it right now with
a tweet can't he can communicate
directly with them
and say go home this is doing no one any
good this is damaging the very
structure the foundations of the united
states of america
well he has uh just recently he put out
a tweet to say
to stay peaceful uh don jr his son is
trying to appeal
for calm right now uh though i i would
say the whole rally
this morning was very ill advice to
begin with
uh and it led to this uh something that
we we
never thought we would see in the united
states uh
and if we could see it it would be from
the political left because most of the
rallies and destruction
around the united states has been from
the political left well that's not the
case anymore
well you know i mentioned the
president's ability to end it all with
it with a tweet the vice president
is trying uh vice president pence who
was
in the senate chamber that has been
taken to a place of safety we understand
and
this has come from mike pence let me
read it to you the violence and
destruction taking place at the u.s
capitol
must stop that's in capitals and it must
stop
now anyone involved must respect law
enforcement officers and immediately
leave
the building peaceful protest it
continues is the right of every american
but this attack on our capital will not
be tolerated and those involved will be
prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law well
rather
coming from vp mike pence wouldn't that
be better
coming from the oval office itself
coming from one
donald j trump yes of course
of course uh however that's just not the
reality right now
uh and i would say a lot of it goes back
to the self-preservation
as we've talked about he doesn't want to
be prosecuted for these uh
decades-old allegations about his taxes
and businesses i mean that's ridiculous
that's what they do in third world
countries yet that's what
people are trying to do to the duly
elected president to treat him basically
like a third world leader so
it's sort of like a vicious cycle what's
going on right now i never thought we
would see the capital
be evacuated by a bob an unruly mob
let alone from the political right yet
that's what we're seeing unfold
well just don't give me your sense
though i i want to get your sense as an
american
not on left or right here just how
worried you are
about the damage being done around the
world now
looking at these scenes and what the
president has has continued to say over
the last two months the damage that is
being done
to american democracy and i know you
also work with george w bush and one
remembers
that hand over period of course george w
bush was a two-term president but
one remembers when we hear it from both
gentlemen just how warm
the handover was between george w bush
and
president obama it doesn't have to be
bitter and it shouldn't be
bitter surely americans should try to
reunite
after a divisive election that's true
i totally agree with that um america is
changing in a lot of ways however
i think what you're seeing is a lot of
jobs go overseas
places like china and mexico from the
united states our manufacturing bases
suffering right now
big tech has really changed the way
people live
and work a lot of small businesses are
going out of business because of big
corporations then you have
big tech in silicon valley suppressing
speech from the right you can't even say
anything about
people so many people losing their jobs
and their in their livelihoods
or else you're called a racist or
nativist and
a lot of people are very frustrated
about that and i think as
as you see corporations get larger and
richer and more
people lose their jobs particularly the
working class lose their jobs
you're going to have a lot of resentment
both on the left and the right that's
why
i mean but but the way to address that
is through the uh the full functions and
wide functions
of the american democratic system isn't
it not
through storming into congress if you
can i just want to share this with you
as well uh we are hearing that one
person is now in a critical condition
after being shot
at the u.s capitol at least five people
have been transported to the hospital
that's according to washington dc
emergency services of those transported
one of those transported was a law
enforcement officer so one law
enforcement officer
injured and one person shot in a
critical condition
and several other people taken to
hospital at least four people have been
transported by ambulance from the
the capital building and that that's to
that point isn't it
there are peaceful democratic processes
so many of them
in the united states and that's the way
to make
change right peaceful protests
and uh i would say that today it clearly
went overboard
um uh like i said this is something that
we've never seen before in america
people need to take a deep breath stand
back
and they need to reform the the voting
system and make sure that
elections are on election day uh we need
to
to to have reforms throughout the 50
states to make sure that
we don't have this type of election
again where there
are all these uh alleged uh voter
uh fraud or voter voting irregularities
and then people
get uh very upset about that and they
believe an election was stolen we need
voting reform across the 50 states
something like we had this year should
never happen again
but you know this was predictable
throughout the year the president should
have predicted this earlier
than now well just coming to the end of
our chat jd gordon much appreciate
talking to you just just give me um your
sense of what you would say
to the presidents about attending the
inauguration in two weeks time would you
say listen
swallow your pride you've got to go
well attending the inauguration may just
encourage
the left to mobilize like this too
because most of the protests
and the violence has been from the
political left so if president trump
attends the inauguration
we could expect this from the political
left so yes i would encourage a peaceful
transition of course but whether
he physically attends the inauguration
or not uh is is not something that that
is necessarily part of a peaceful
transition in this case because america
has changed
so much i appreciate you spending the
time talking to us jd gordon thank you
very much indeed as we take in those
extraordinary scenes on the very steps
of the capitol building in the heart of
washington dc disrupting proceedings
there they have been
suspended the building we understand is
in lockdown and the political
representatives of the american people
are either sheltering in place some of
them are being taken out
of the building including the vice
president mike pence to a place of
safety well let's go
down amongst the crowds there somewhere
in skies
sally lockwood and uh sally just
tell us what you've heard in terms of
developments and what's going on around
you
we might be able to hear the chanting
uh it's getting increasingly boisterous
down here
there's been some banging in the last
few minutes which
sounded like protesters banging on the
sides of the capitol building
very just a few meters from where i'm
standing on the door and on the windows
and then there was a huge cheer i'm not
sure whether that's because
someone managed to make it back inside
the capitol building
again but i've just met uh mitchell and
his
his father mark who who are here are
part of the crowd and mitchell
was one of those who made it inside a
capitol building
uh in the last hour or so uh mitchell
why did you want to go inside and what
was it like when you did
one for history one for documentation
also as a person as a patriot as an
american
we have the right to choose not them and
what do you feel is being pulled down
uh every terrible terrible politician
of the politicians in this country in
every city
eight counties they are everywhere
and they are very sick people very
articles awful people who never really
care about themselves well
what we're we're the thing here is
obviously it's very violent and
a bit of unrest some people are
describing this crowd as an unreally mob
would you say this is an unruly mall but
you and i'm really
no unruly
to restore the rule of law to restore
the constitution
they're trampled over and not heard
about
the laws they live by their laws and
then they force
the laws onto us and they don't they
don't fight violence
is what you're doing here disrespecting
democracy can you just not take
the fact that donald trump hasn't won
the election you don't need to react
like that
well for one we live in a program
right we seem to be uh having
difficulties uh getting a decent sound
feed from
sally there will be getting much more
from her during the course of this
evening looks like it's gonna be a long
one
as we monitor those developments outside
the u.s capital latest we're hearing
this from the pentagon that the national
guard
are being called into washington d.c and
reports
of a shooting one person in critical
condition
five law enforcement officers injured
stay with us
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
the angry final days of donald trump's
presidency as his supporters converge
on congress protesters forced america's
lawmakers into
lockdown after senior republicans make
clear they will
not overturn the election result
the president deserted by his deputy
tell supporters he will not give in
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's death
involved
well tonight as the president is accused
of causing this insurrection the latest
live from washington
also tonight the deadliest day since
april more than a thousand
more deaths from covid are recorded
my exams are out and teacher assessed
grades are in for a levels and gcses
for this month's btec exams are on
and the warning from south africa over
its own variant and its potential
to blunt the impact of vaccines
plus still going for gold despite the
pandemic we meet the british olympians
who has to believe the games will go
ahead
well hello good evening they've been
astonishing scenes in washington tonight
as a group of
trump supporters clashed with police at
capitol hill
one person has been shot by law
enforcement and is in a critical
condition
several people have been treated for
injuries well police say a number of
people have reached the capitol building
and the area has been put into lockdown
congress has been meeting to formally
endorse the electoral votes
from last year's election and find joe
biden the next president
a short time ago though the senate
chamber evacuated
the vice president uh forced to be taken
to a secure location
at the violent scenes followed a letter
from vice president mike pence who
rejected calls
by donald trump to throw out the
election where sky city lockwood is
amongst the protesters who are still
there donald trump himself calling for
um a peaceful protest but not
calling the crowds off bring us up to
date sally
yeah donald trump may be calling for a
peaceful protest now anna but that horse
has bolted
uh it is not peaceful here there are
protesters flanking against the side of
the capital building which has
already been breached uh we understand
one person has been shot by law
enforcement
after people made it into the capitol
building it's unclear
whether the person was shot inside or
outside of the building was certainly in
the capital
ground and we're also hearing now anna
that several law enforcement officials
have said at least
one improvised explosive device
has been found on the us capitol grounds
now we don't know exactly where
whether it was just in the ground or
whether it made it inside the building
but that is what we are now hearing the
latest on the ground here on capitol
hill
is the law enforcement officials say at
least
one improvised explosive device has been
found now the national guard has been
called
by washington dc's mayor to help with
police
uh support with this situation which is
still unfolding and the mayor has also
called a city-wide curfew at six o'clock
tonight
until tomorrow morning in a bid to try
and bring the situation under control
but it certainly feels far from under
control
at the moment anna an fbi official has
also
said that the fbi has been deployed to
assist the u.s
capitol police partners with protection
of federal property and public safety so
that's the latest that we're hearing as
well and
the fbi has now also been deployed here
to assist
the police and the national guard with
this unfolding situation
yes a number of law enforcement agencies
sending as you said the national guard
deployed to the us capital along with
other federal protective services that's
according to a white house spokeswoman
virginia sending their national guard to
200 state troopers
to washington the mayor as you said
asking for that curfew from 6 p.m
and meanwhile the pictures from inside
from earlier
quite extraordinary as the crowd tried
to get into the
the us capitol buildings at one point
held back it looked like by one security
guard with something like
a truncheon as they moved their way
upstairs um
waving the confederate flag as well
sally and that's the interesting thing
these are
latest pictures uh as you can see of
some of these i'm ambling through
these uh trump supporters ambling
through uh with the u.s
and uh later on you might see the
confederate flag as well
as they moved their way in filming
themselves as you can see
heading upstairs and meanwhile in the
chambers um people
locking the doors and being told to to
grab their their their gas masks sally
yes that's right it really does feel uh
as though there is
a sense of lawlessness here anna i spoke
to
a a protester a short time ago who told
me how he made it
inside the capitol building it was
pepper frayed he saw
armed police inside uh standing uh
in a sort of human wall to try and keep
protesters back
we understand tear gas has been fired
and those in congress were given
uh gas masks before they were evacuated
using
underground corridors underground
tunnels
now um we understand that the building
isn't locked down now
although it doesn't feel necessarily
that law enforcement have taken control
of this situation
given the number of people in the area
and
the sense of us rest here it really does
feel a matter of time
before there is some sort of
intervention from the police
from the agencies working together now
to try and bring the situation under
control
i think we can expect to see that
certainly in the coming hours
absolutely the us house republican
leader kevin mccarthy
uh told one u.s network that the protest
activity at the u.s capitol
is unamerican it must stop now but then
he went on to say that he'd talked to
president trump
and urged him to issue a statement to
calm down protesters
trump then issued this tweet please
support
our capitol police and law enforcement
they are truly on the side of the
country
stay peaceful let's listen now to the
vice president-elect joe biden
[Applause]
times we've ever seen it an assault
on most sacred of american undertakings
the doing of the people's business
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must end
now i call on this mob
to pull back and allow the work of
democracy to go
forward you've heard me say before in
different contexts
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
and therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
to storm the capitol to smash windows
to occupy offices the floor of the
united states senate
rummaging through desks on the capitol
on the house of representatives
threatening the safety of dually elected
officials it's not protest
it's insurrection
the world's watching like so many other
americans
i am generally shocked and saddened that
our nation
so long the beacon of light and hope for
democracy
has come to such a dark moment
through war and strife america has
endured much
and we will endure here and we will
prevail again
and will prevail now the work of the
moment
and the work of the next four years must
be the restoration
of democracy of decency honor
respect the rule of law
just plain simple decency
the renewal of the politics it's about
solving problems looking out for one
another
not stoking the flames of hate and chaos
as i said america is about honor
decency respect tolerance
that's who we are that's who we've
always been
the certification electric the electoral
college vote
supposed to be a sacred ritual which we
affirm
purposes to affirm the majesty of
american democracy
but today's reminder a painful one
that democracy is fragile and to
preserve it
requires people of good will leaders
of the courage to stand up who are
devoted not to the pursuit of power
or the personal interest pursuits of
their own selfish interests
at any cost but of the common good
think what our children watching
television is thinking
think what the rest of the world is
looking at
for nearly two and a half centuries
we the people in search of a more
perfect union
ever kept our eyes on that common good
america's so much better than what we're
seeing today
[Music]
watching the scenes from the capitol
i was reminded as i prepared other
speeches in the past it was reminded of
the
words of abraham lincoln and his annual
message to congress
whose work has today been interrupted by
chaos
here's what lincoln said
he said we shall nobly save or merely
lose the last best
hope on earth went on to say
the way is plain peaceful
generous just
a way which if followed
the world will forever applaud and god
must forever bless
the way is playing here too that's who
we are
it's the way of democracy
of respect of decency of
honor
and commitment is patriots to this
nation
notwithstanding what i saw today we're
seeing today
i remain optimistic about the incredible
opportunities
there's never been anything we can't do
when we do it together
and this god-awful display today
is bringing home to every republican and
democrat and independent in the nation
that we must step up this is the united
states of america there's never
ever ever ever ever been a thing we've
tried to do
that we've done it together we've not
been able to do it
so president trump step up
god bless america may god protect our
troops
and all those folks at the capitol who
are trying to preserve
order thank you and i'm sorry to have
kept you waiting
well joe biden there in full outrage as
you heard there
this is a small number of extremists he
called
uh wanted president trump to call off
this mob demanding that he goes
on air and demands an end to this siege
of the capital
storming the capital smashing windows
banging down doors this is insurrection
joe biden said
the world is watching i am shocked and
saddened
the u.s so long a beacon of hope and
light in democracy
well the world is indeed watching the
british prime minister
boris johnson has just tweeted
disgraceful scenes
in u.s congress the united states stands
for democracy around the
world and it is now vital that there
should be a peaceful
and orderly transfer of power the
canadian prime minister said he thought
the
u.s institutions are strong hopefully
everything
will return to normal shortly the german
foreign minister
said the enemies of democracy will be
pleased at these unbearable
images from washington uh his supporters
trump supporters must accept the
decision
of the american people at last so
certainly as i said
the world is indeed watching well let's
get the latest then from the
scene sally lockwood is there sally uh
you started
reporting on this 24 hours ago and
supporters of president trump began
gathering there what had they been
expecting
well a number of people have only grown
since i first reported
the scenes here to you last night anna
they were largely
peaceful protests uh last night there
were some clashes with police
some arrests uh as donald trump
supporters
made their way to black lives matter
plaza but today of course things
really have escalated to
an almost unfathomable level it's hard
to
believe that we're looking at the uh one
of the most iconic buildings
in america surrounded now by people who
are trying to get inside uh
i mean you could call this a riot i
suppose
but certainly uh violent scenes uh as
you get close to one of the chamber
entrances with people
pushing against the door and windows
still trying to get in
uh and of course those uh people that we
saw those protesters who made it into
at the capitol building earlier it took
police a couple of hours to clear them
and of course was
terrifying for the members of congress
inside who were given gas masks
after tear gas was deployed now we are
hearing that vice president mike pence
is still inside uh the capitol building
we were told that
been moved to a safe location we weren't
sure whether that was away from capitol
hill
but we understand he is still inside
uh the capital and he won't leave until
it becomes safe for him
to do so but for now he remains secure
inside we've also heard reports
that several law enforcement officials
say at least one
improvised explosive device has been
found
on the grounds of the us capital and of
course one person
has been shot and yet standing in a
critical
condition with a chest with this
situation
still unfolding here anna but certainly
very volatile indeed yes and just to add
to that
actually we're just hearing from a
spokesperson
from the rnc the republican national
committee that earlier today a
suspicious device was found
at their headquarters rnc staff
they say were safely evacuated from the
building and the device has been
successfully
detonated by a bomb squad to just
add to that earlier report about a
device uh
reported uh on the u.s capitol grounds
so clearly that um
is very serious development uh just
hearing also
that trump will have a taped message
coming shortly this is according to a
senior
white house official we heard president
uh elect joe biden
suggesting that he should very urgently
get on the airwaves
and demand an end to this siege at the
u.s capitol
certainly with the number of law
enforcement on the way perhaps now the
white house is taking this
extremely seriously as we watch those
pictures outside where you are
sally uh still people on megaphones
trying to g up the crowd
and continue the protest but uh no doubt
we will very soon here hear
from the current u.s president mr trump
yes it'll be very interesting indeed uh
to hear from donald trump
now as we see these rather unnerving
seats
unfold in america's capital uh around
uh defeat of democracy here
in america of course donald trump
addressed his supporters at that
save america rally this afternoon
speaking for
around an hour and urging them to take
part in this march today
up to capitol hill to protest the
election result donald trump
hasn't accepted the result of this
election he hasn't conceded
if anything he's only riled up his face
so all
this trust and division uh following
this election
but two weeks out from the adult
inauguration
uh it's hard to believe the election was
two months ago at these
things we are witnessing and of course
just to remind you there was that
extraordinary open letter which is this
week by
the ten living former defense
secretaries
warning against the use of the military
because that is a concern that donald
trump
would potentially try to use the
military to somehow stay in the white
house this student's time
an unprecedented situation with america
fighting themselves tonight
well sally let's just listen now to uh
those words of president trump a little
earlier where he talked about the
the theft of the u.s election we will
never give up we will never concede it
doesn't happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved
states want to revoke the states
got defrauded they were given false
information
they voted on it now they want to
recertify they want it back
all vice president pence has to do is
send it back to the states
to recertify and we become
president and you are the happiest
people
well the accusation by some has been
that undermining democracy is no way to
win a senate runoff it does appear now
that the democrat john ossoff
has won that second seat in georgia
beating the incumbent there senator
david perdue
a fascinating contest down in georgia
obviously
republicans some of them furious at
president trump's intervention
uh down there that does of course mean
that the senate with the casting vote of
uh soon-to-be vice president kamala
harris is in the hands of the democrats
for the first time in six years which no
doubt will
aggravate the crowds now outside the
capitol building
the u.s president has put out a message
on twitter we'll bring that to you as
soon as we can
but sally what will happen now if law
enforcement heads there
will they heed the words of president
trump if he indeed asks them to disband
or might we see confrontations into the
afternoon and evening
i can't hear you too well anna but i
think you are asking about
uh law enforcement and how they're
dealing with this situation well we know
that it's a multi-agency response
now the fbi uh have deployed teams
at the national guard uh were pulled in
by the mayor of washington dc and of
course there's uh
local police as well uh
we're not it's not quite clear what the
strategy is at the moment but i can't
see
uh law enforcement allowing this to
continue for much longer i think there
will be some sort of response
uh in the coming hours and i imagine it
will be
quite significant i just say joe biden
we have heard from
uh of course uh in the last hour but
he's also just tweeted
of course uh joe biden the democrats
should be celebrating
uh that incredible victory in georgia
that's just broken but instead he's
tweeting
about this situation here on capitol
hill and he's written
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol do not represent who we
are
what we are seeing is a small number of
extremists dedicated to lawlessness
this is not defensive disorder it
borders on tradition
and it must end now well
uh from what we're seeing here and it
doesn't feel like it's going to end
anytime soon but washington dc's mayor
has
uh implemented an emergency curfew at 6
00 pm tonight in a bid
to try and make people leave the area
but
the majority of the people that are here
anna aren't from washington
dc uh the advice to residents apologies
i'm going to interrupt you if you don't
mind we have now had that pre-recorded
video from president trump
he calls on his supporters telling them
we love you you're very special
to go home but again repeats uh the
falsehoods that led you might argue to
today's violence
about the fraudulent election let's
listen
i know you're paying i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us
from me from you from our country this
was a fraudulent
election but we can't play into the
hands of these people
we have to have peace so go home
we love you you're very special you've
seen what happens
you see the way others are treated that
are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
[Applause]
well there we are the words of the u.s
president uh once again reiterating that
he believes it was a fraudulent election
which led even uh the republican senator
mitt romney to say that trump has caused
this
insurrection but asking his supporters
to go
home uh fascinating that it comes now
his earlier tweet talked about being
peaceful
sally will they heed um heed him do you
think
it doesn't feel like anyone's really
paying much attention to anything other
than what's happening around them here
anna
i mean had he said that to his
supporters uh
earlier on when he was addressing them
at that rally it may have made a
difference but
it feels really too little too late for
donald trump to now be calling for them
to be peaceful
and to go home and in the same breath
describing it as a fraudulent election
and a landslide to him beta jig
isn't clear and i doubt it will be
effective
uh because he's stolen the seas of
distrust in what's happened
in the last two months since that
election in november people here feel
wrong they feel that this election has
been stolen from them they believe every
word that donald trump
has said about the election of seeing
a stolen election and people here are
angry
and is this miseducation and
misinformation from
donald trump that have perpetuated that
feeling
so for him to release a twitter video
now asking them to be peaceful and to go
home
well really it feels like too little too
late and certainly
it has made very little difference here
so far
given that people knew he'd called for a
wild day
and they knew since yesterday that trump
supporters were massing
uh and and planning this march will
there be questions about the security i
mean you had scenes where protester
occupied the u.s senate president's
chair on the diocese in the senate
chamber
they were banging at the door of the of
the house chamber
guns were drawn uh people were told to
go under their chairs and grab their gas
masks you know
they shouldn't be allowable should it
know absolutely unimaginable scenes
that have played out in the last few
hours here and uh
the most iconic uh building in america
perhaps
uh just completely engulfed in chaos
and of course those members of congress
yes sheltering for their own safety
uh as american citizens stormed the
building
absolutely extraordinary scene
now we did see huge police presence here
and of course the national guard
we didn't anticipate that the scenes
would descend
to the level of chaos that we are seeing
now given the
number of police in washington dc ahead
of this
uh protest today but lawrenceville we
are here at the law enforcement is in
the process
of destroying the improvised explosive
devices that were found
on the capitol grounds that's the latest
that we're hearing anna of course
we brought that news to you in the last
hour that at least one
iep one improvised explosive device has
been found
in the grounds of the capital and we
understand that that is
the law enforcement aren't in the
process of destroying that
uh it's not clear whether they were
functional
or not but we're hearing that one was
made of a small section
of galvanized pipe like a pipe bomb is
being described
so people who came
to capitol hill to take part in this
march today certainly
came here not only to behave violently
but perhaps
to do even more damage than that that's
interesting so um
at least one explosive device that
you're talking about found near the us
capital
is no longer a threat uh we're hearing
from um
ap associated press news agency
according to law enforcement officials
and this second device and indeed it was
a separate device
uh that the rnc staff reported
they were safely evacuated from their
headquarters
the device has been successfully
detonated by a bomb squad
so two different devices it does appear
uh dominic raab
uk foreign secretary has said the us
rightly takes great pride
in its democracy and there can be no
justification for these violent attempts
to frustrate the lawful
and proper transition of power reaction
coming in
not surprisingly from around the world
certainly on this
president trump has now called for his
supporters
to go home but what he did call for
earlier
was his vice president mike prince to
intervene
effectively in the will of the people
this formal
ratification which had been due today of
the u.s
election vote back in early november
he'd called for him to intervene
something that
mike pence said he could not do he said
the constitution constrains me
from claiming unilateral authority to
determine
which electoral votes could be or should
be counted rather
and which should not and i read that
those uh
certificates of electoral votes were
grabbed in fact
as senators evacuated from the chamber
so senate parliamentary staff secured
those electoral college certificates as
they were evacuated
from the senate chamber what trump had
to say about all of that
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country
and our constitution giving states a
chance to certify a corrected set of
facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify
the usa demands the truth he had said of
that but uh
all of it suspended obviously because of
the protests
the storming of the u.s capitol building
and sally are questions being asked or
will they in the coming days well
from november i guess about what this
has done to the reputation of
of democracy in america
well certainly there's huge distrust of
democracy
among many republican voters indeed
uh one poll suggesting uh that a
majority
of republican voters distrust the system
and don't think that this was
a fair election uh which is extremely
worrying
that americans can't trust the process
of democracy
in this country the fact that this
ceremonial
event this ceremonial vote that was
taking part in congress today
has become the focus of such unrest
when it's not the job of congress to
question
the vote it's simply their role today to
certify
the results that have already been
verified
at state level yet there's this distrust
in what has happened in this election
that people feel that
they've there's been widespread fraud
and significant i'm doing we've just um
heard a bang you may have heard that and
i'm not sure
what it was but it looks like law
enforcement
are moving in and pushing the protesters
away from the capitol building
police in riot gear have just turned up
that bang i'm not
entirely sure what it was uh but there
was some smoke and a bag and it started
moving
uh protesters away there's a human wall
of police with
uh fire gear now moving in all the
protesters sort of surrounded the
capital building
uh by the entrance of one of the
chambers where we're standing now where
windows have been
broken and whether it's a crowd of
hundreds certainly the protesters
outnumber the police here anna okay
that's interesting uh
sally obviously take care and uh
hopefully you might be able to find out
what that is
uh donald trump's message which had been
put out on twitter
um it now says underneath it this claim
of election ford is disputed
and this tweet can't be replied to
retweeted or liked due to a risk of
violence
uh that from uh twitter pictures as you
can see
still of the protesters who are still
outside the u.s capitol despite that
plea now from donald trump
who said he feels and shares their pain
at the
fraudulent vote uh to go home perhaps
some of them are we will wait to find
out certainly
in the meantime let's re-listen shall we
to the
vice president and the a president-elect
apologies
joe biden our democracy is under
unprecedented assault
unlike anything we've seen in modern
times
an assault on the citadel of liberty
the capital itself
an assault on the people's
representatives
and the capitol hill police sworn to
protect them
and the public servants who work
at the heart of our republic
an assault on the rule of law
like few times we've ever seen it
an assault on most sacred of american
undertakings the doing of the people's
business
me be very clear the scenes of chaos at
the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must
end now
i call on this mob to pull back
and allow the work of democracy to go
forward
you've heard me say before in different
contexts
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
to storm the capital to smash windows
to occupy offices the floor of the
united states senate
rummaging through desks on the capitol
on the house of representatives
threatening the safety of dually elected
officials it's not protest
it's insurrection
the world's watching like
so many other americans i am generally
shocked and saddened that our nation
so long the beacon of light and hope for
democracy
has come to such a dark moment
through war and strife america has
endured much
and we will endure here and we will
prevail again
and will prevail now the work of the
moment
and the work of the next four years must
be the restoration
of democracy of decency honor
respect the rule of law
just plain simple decency
the renewal of the politics it's about
solving problems looking out for one
another
not stoking the flames of hate and chaos
as i said america is about honor
decency respect tolerance
that's who we are that's who we've
always been
the certification electric the electoral
college vote
supposed to be a sacred ritual which we
affirm
purposes to affirm the majesty of
american democracy
but today is a reminder a painful one
that democracy is fragile and to
preserve it
requires people of good will leaders
with the courage to stand up
who are devoted not to the pursuit of
power
but or the personal interest pursuits of
their own
selfish interest at any cost but of the
common good
think what our children watching
television is thinking
think what the rest of the world is
looking at
joe biden speaking a short time ago well
as you can see i'm joined now from
washington by nancy
mace republican congresswoman for south
carolina who is now in a different
building
from the u.s capitol and what happened
for you
and all other politicians in in the
capitol buildings nancy
right i was in the joint session
initially and
when we went to recess on the first
objection to arizona's electoral
votes the electoral college uh canon
office building where i am right now the
office was evacuated because there was a
pipe bomb
that was delivered to the republican
party headquarters or the rnc
just a short distance from here when we
were able to come back to our offices we
then went into a lockdown because
protesters at that juncture
had had breached the capitol and were
attacking the capitol police and law
enforcement officers
this is the sad day for our nation i'm
devastated
and i'm angry this is an american
and i'm asking the president to get off
twitter and to get on tv
i'm begging him to calm these folks down
to ask them to follow the rule of law
and to ask them to go home
you're angry but who do you blame
i blame the folks who have used rhetoric
to take advantage of millions of
americans millions of americans have
been misled
on what we're doing here today at the
capitol this was a ceremonial
vote on the electoral college um this is
this was not a place and millions of
americans believe that
that congress unilaterally could
overturn the results of the electoral
college
millions of americans believe that
singularly the vice president
as president mike pence could overturn
the results of the electoral college
today and that's just not
that's just not true they were they were
dishonestly lied to
and that's why you're seeing these
emotions run high i think they're
realizing
the reality of the election now and
they've been misled
and it's incumbent upon our leadership
to to set the example to ask these
people to pro
peacefully protest to stop the violence
and to go home
and i'm asking your president to ask
them to do the same
well from what you're saying then you
fully blame
president trump for this and indeed his
son eric who was threatening
senators with primaries yesterday if
they didn't support the action
um is it indeed the man in the white
house who's led to these
extraordinary scenes of the capital
building being breached
well a threat to primary someone that is
that is
uh that is america that is the elections
uh
we have primaries that's not an act of
violence but i've seen rhetoric
from multiple members of even my own
party
some of the language that's been used i
will tell you i had my children here
this weekend
and because of the rhetoric leading up
to the vote this week
i put them on the first flight home on
monday because my instinct
my gut was this isn't this isn't right
i'm worried that the rhetoric
will encourage violence and my greatest
fears came true today thank god i
listened to my motherly
instincts and i sent my children home
this was going to be a week for them
to really enjoy and see and witness
history
and instead it's turned into a nightmare
and i'm devastated for our nation
and the impact of america's reputation
uh on democracy democracy around the
world is that also impacted by these
scenes
no it is when america is strong the rest
of the world is strong
and this is we're not exhibiting that
strength today we have a constitution
and we are a republic and we can't burn
it all down
today i mean there are folks who want to
put a zippo lighter to the constitution
because they didn't like the outcome of
the election i'm a huge supporter of
president trump
i worked for him on his campaign in
2016. i supported him
all throughout the last four years but
all of that was wiped out today
president trump has recorded a message
which has been played
uh no doubt on the us networks uh and uh
on social media
but in it he does say to these
supporters
i share your pain we were robbed but
you've got to go home
does he need to be stronger than that
now do you think
um i i haven't watched the entire video
i think the first message needs to be
that we have law and order our nation if
we're going to protest it needs to be
peaceful and if it's not
going to be peaceful you need to go home
we can argue the merits and investigate
voter fraud
another day today is not the day to be
debating that issue it is an issue that
i feel
voters paint on i i worked very hard to
get donald trump elected and
in 2016 as a huge supporter of his he
supported my campaign for congress
but now is not the time we need to
advocate for peace we need to advocate
for people to follow the law
we need to ask these people to go home
well we're watching pictures while
you're speaking of what we would call
here in the uk
riot police they're certainly uh they
have protective equipment on put it that
way the supporters of
of mr trump are still in situ do you
fear
what might happen later i know the dc
mayor has called for a curfew from 6 p.m
tonight
i i do and and what people don't realize
what some of these elected
uh officials don't realize is rhetoric
has
real consequences they are they have
seeded this
and they are they are reaping that day
it's disgusting
it's un-american and it needs to stop
and i'm not going to stop with that
message until it ends
and it needs to end now it needs to end
today and i'm asking the president to
get off
get off twitter get on tv advocate for
peace
advocate for a peaceful end to this and
ask these people to go home
you heard a president's joe biden
possibly uh
in part of um his address which we just
played before you
are calling for a restoration of
democracy decency and honor
will you support him in that work do you
think even though he is a
soon to be a democratic president um of
course that's my duty as a member of
congress
i am a constitutional conservative i
believe in the republic
and that's what we were voting on today
i was not going to vote to
object i was going to vote to certify
the election this vote today was
ceremonial it was
administrative more or less congress
didn't have the right
to overturn the results of the election
today the vice president doesn't have
the right or the power to do that
either but still given that uh the the
misleading the dishonesty by some
members of my own party on this issue
this is where we are today because of
that um and i'm sad for our nation i'm
sad for
my district we are better than this this
is not who
who we are and it's it's a sad day for
our nation
and could the vice president mike pence
who obviously played a crucial role in
the formalities of today could he have
come out earlier and been more clear
that he was not going to intervene to
change the will of the people
i have not been able to see what or when
uh the vice president
has said i know that vice president
pence cares about the
american people i know that earlier
today he did share that he would not be
objecting to the electoral college
because he didn't have the
constitutional ability power or
authority to do that
i understand he's also put a statement
out about the violence
and i praise his leadership during this
time i'm asking our president
to be more vocal get on tv talk to these
people
please ask them to do the right thing
because i know that personally
i've been threatened with violence i
know other members of congress have i'm
sure it's happening on social media in
our communities
and it's gotta end you cannot fight
violence with violence we are not the
radical left we're better than this
we're the party of law and order or at
least i thought we were
yes mike pence has said the violence and
destruction taking place at the u.s
capitol
must stop and it must stop now anyone
involved must respect law enforcement
officers
and immediately leave the building those
were his words from earlier
just one final thought if you don't mind
i know you've got plenty of people to
speak to and
lots to digest about what has happened
today and what happens now in terms of
the formalities
of recognizing those electoral college
votes then
you know you said you were in recess
will it all have to start again tomorrow
i don't know i think it'll be dependent
on when this ends today if it ends today
right now we're unable to do anything we
i wanted to send my junior staff home if
it was safe to go home and right now
we're all in lockdown on the capitol
right at this moment because of the
violence and the protests and the
anarchy happening on our capitol steps
well nancy mace republican congresswoman
for south carolina
much appreciate you joining us so soon
after having to leave the uh the capitol
building thank you very much indeed
well let's remind ourselves what
president trump had to say in a video
then
on twitter a short time ago i know
you're paying
i know you're hurt we had an election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us
from me from you from our country this
was a fraudulent
election but we can't play into the
hands of these people
we have to have peace so go home
we love you you're very special you've
seen what happens
you see the way others are treated that
are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
well let's speak now to nicole brennan
schmitz democratic strategist thank you
indeed for joining us
so you have trump supporters
uh carrying confederate flags moving
into the senate chamber
what a day
yeah it's pretty unbelievable and
um it's certainly it's not protesters
this is domestic terrorism this is an
attempted coup and it's no longer
bloodless there have been shots fired
there are injuries
and it's horrific
what should happen now in fact we're
looking at scenes inside now live i
think there were previous scenes
actually of
of effectively um
standoffs i guess between capital hill
police and some of the protesters
they look like tear gas were thrown as
well if you look at these pictures
uh this is people trying to get in or
the protection
guns drawn and people hiding
being told to hide under their seats and
grab gas masks
did you ever think it would come to this
i know i know people that talked about a
wild day
save america march they called it did
you ever think it would come to this
uh i didn't i i thought that we were
ready to take them at their word that
they were going to come and
and protest and that perhaps they'd be a
little more prepared but i don't think
anyone was ready for
the senate and the house floors to be uh
under siege i mean i've spent
i can't tell you how my dad was a
staffer on capitol hill i'm
in and out of the capitol for my country
i do apologize we're just going to
interrupt you there is a news conference
underway let's listen
came to our city this morning to
exercise their first amendment rights
and were largely concentrated in the
area of the national mall
following the president's remarks a
large crowd began to march eastbound on
madison avenue northwest
and constitution avenue northwest as the
demonstrators approached the united
states capitol grounds
there was a noticeable change in their
demeanor
they breached the fencing along the u.s
capitol grounds
and confronted police lines surrounding
the building
mpd was requested by the united states
by the united states capitol police
to provide assistance with crowd
management
and due to the violent behavior towards
the police officers there
and their intent on gaining access to
the to the capitol
a riot was declared it was clear that
the crowd was intent on causing harm
to our officers by deploying chemical
irritants on police
to force entry into the united states
capitol building
as you are aware they were able to gain
access to the capitol building
and i can can confirm that one civilian
was reported to have sustained
a gunshot wound inside of the capitol
details of the shooting are not
immediately available and the situation
remains under investigation the
metropolitan police department
will be taking the lead on that
investigation mpd
continues to provide personnel resources
and assistance on the grounds
of the u.s capitol and has requested the
assistance of law enforcement partners
through a previously in place mutual aid
agreement as you heard from the mayor a
6 pm curfew
has been put in place tonight and will
be in effect until 6 a.m
tomorrow january 7th we are advising
everyone everyone that is not engaged in
essential activity
to get off the streets and adhere to the
curfew if you are found to be in
violation of the curfew
police will be required to take action
again i want to reiterate and make it
clear please abide by the curfew that
the mayor has set in place
or people will be subject to arrest
lastly
i know that many of you are familiar
with the metropolitan police department
understand that there is no better
agency in the country to handle
first amendment events they happen on a
regular basis here in our city
however today's events were not
representation of peaceful protests
today what we witnessed was unlawful
riotous
behavior and people that come to our
city engaged in unlawful behavior
will be held accountable we can take any
questions
after that you may have after the
secretary has a chance to speak
thank you mayor bowser chief conte at
around three o'clock this afternoon we
mobilized the dc national
guard to 100 strength we'll have 1100
personnel
that are convening to the armory as we
speak to support metro pd
and reestablishing the safety and the
confines of the u.s capitol
we'll also be working with other federal
law enforcement entities
that are coming here to the metropolitan
police station to add additional support
and capability
as they continue deliberate planning and
look into how a clearing operation will
be conducted
thank you and how does this work
this phone okay
okay
yeah uh mayor and chief grazie uh could
you please
speak to the confusion surrounding the
deployment of the national guard
we understand that the council put out a
statement saying that originally the
department of defense
refused to allow the dc guard to
reinforce capital police officers at the
capitol can you clarify what happened
there
i'm not sure what statement you're
referring to evan but
but let me be clear i requested on guard
assistance i guess
two or three days ago in
in supporting the d.c government's
operations the metropolitan police
department traffic box
and that request was approved by the
secretary of the army
additionally as i understand and i'll
turn to the secretary to speak to this
directly
the united states capitol police
department uh requested
additional guard support on today so let
me go to the
to the secretary hi this is ryan
mccarthy
uh when we were working through the
additional requests there was
uh i'm sorry confused by that the uh
there was additional requests that came
forward from the capitol police
and for us to truly understand the
specifics behind their requests and how
we would support the operations
a lot of questions were asked a little
bit of confusion
but as we worked through it we
multiplied the determination about a
half hour later to mobilize the entire
dc national guard
so uh this has been incredibly fluid but
uh i
i have to go through the secretary of
defense ultimately get
the final approval to mobilize uh
personnel
as well as to conduct operations uh in
cooperation and coordination
with local authorities
ali wamu
ali wamu
the city-wide curfew mayor that can't
apply to federal
property correct the the curfew applies
across the city and we will if your
question is
are people who are on the capitol ground
subject to the curfew
they're going to be subject to following
the lawful orders
of a police on the grounds and they will
be ordered to evacuate the capitol
grounds
next question by the police
next question mayor is nick from the ap
nick from the ap
right there
so we will leave the dc memorial bowser
insisting once again that this curfew
which comes in
at 6 p.m is enforceable do take
heed plenty more from washington where
protesters
have been trying to overthrow the
results of november's election
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is sky news at 10
live from washington
our top story the angry final days of
donald trump's presidency
as his supporters force america's
politicians into lockdown
at least one person is shot improvised
explosives are found
after senior republicans make clear they
will not
overturn the election result
the president deserted by his deputy is
defiant
but tells his supporters they need to
step back
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now
tonight as the president is accused of
causing insurrection
his successor calls for the violence to
stop
it's disorder is chaos
it borders on sedition and it must
end now
also on sky news at 10 the deadliest day
since april
a thousand more deaths from covid
recorded
and the students told they'll set exams
in lockdown
but a-levels and gcses will now be
teacher assessed
[Music]
well good evening from washington it is
the night that should
deliver the coup de gras to donald
trump's campaign to hold on
to the white house but america's
president was instead tonight
accused of provoking what some would
call an attempted coup
his supporters massed outside congress
and then forced their way
in leading to the suspension of the
session which was due to confirm joe
biden
as the next president one person is in a
critical condition after being shot
and improvised explosive devices have
been found the chaos followed senior
republicans including vice president
like mike pence
making clear they would not overturn the
results of the election
it was literally an attack on democracy
supporters of donald trump scuffling
with police inside the united states
capital
outside thousands have besieged the
building
even at a time when everything seems
remarkable in american politics
these are astonishing scenes
inside the chamber security personnel
with guns drawn at the windows
members of congress sheltering in place
on the floor people taking
what they could as souvenirs at least
one person was shot critically injured
police say
others were injured in the clashes the
chaos and violence indicative of a
country riven
and a slice of the population unwilling
to accept defeat
they've been sent on their way by a
president almost two weeks to the moment
when he'll leave the white house for the
final time
continuing to make the case he didn't
really lose at all
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them what he called the evidence
has already been debunked but
as he was speaking his own vice
president was taking his place in
congress
for what's usually a formality of
certifying his and trump's defeat
would he adhere to the constitution or
bow to trump's pressure to somehow try
and overturn the election we got our
answer before he started speaking
that's my statement yes sir is my
statement out he says
that statement that he did not have the
authority to reject the votes
still plenty of republicans continue to
object
is the objection in writing and signed
by a senator
yes it is it is
it would mean hours of debate but the
outcome is inevitable
and senior republicans now defying trump
this election were overturned by mere
allegations from the losing side
our democracy would enter a death spiral
it wasn't long after the process was
suspended because of the violence
outside
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must end
now the calls for calm from the
president came long after the violence
had started
i know your pain i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
but never is the anger and division in
america being quite so direct
and two weeks out from this place
hosting what should be the peaceful
transition of power
what are the chances all of this ends
with donald trump's presidency
greg milam sky news washington
well sally lockwood is down with the
protesters on capitol hill there and
sally what's the latest there is that
that curfew draws near
yeah greg in the last hour police in
riot gear and swat teams have moved in
to the protesters who were gathered
outside this entrance
to one of the chambers at the capitol
building for the last couple of hours
they moved in with tear gas
and flash bangs and they have managed to
clear them successfully away from
the entrance where we understand windows
have been broken and of course where we
saw those scenes earlier
of protesters uh storming the building
and getting into the chambers
members of congress having to be
evacuated and given gas masks there is a
standoff at the moment now
between police and remaining protesters
some who've been shouting uh things like
traitors
and trump one has definitely calmed down
here
it's really down to just a few hundred
hardcore protesters
that are left but there were thousands
here until around half an
hour ago it has calmed down here but of
course there has been
surreal scenes here today one improvised
explosive device
at least one has been found and rendered
safety
rendered safe in the grounds of the
capital and of course as we know
uh one person was shot by law
enforcement but absolutely surreal
scenes here are one of the most iconic
buildings
in america to see it engulfed in chaos
like that
and as we saw from president trump not
only today at his rally
but for months now when you're president
of the united states
words matter
sally there on capitol hill thank you
very much for that well you might say
the seeds of what happened today were
sown
on election day just over two months ago
but perhaps
it happened far longer ago when a
maverick outsider candidate
became president of the united states
our foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes looks back at how we got
here
[Music]
the president started sowing seeds of
doubt in the fairness of the election
long before polling day he warned
repeatedly without evidence
how democrats might cheat their way to
victory
it helped create a climate of suspicion
and conspiracy
as votes were counted his supporters
then quick to believe their president
when he refused to accept joe biden's
win
this is a fraud on the american public
this
is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
mail-in ballots in the firing line the
reliability of voting machines
also baselessly called into question a
team of lawyers
then turned these allegations of fraud
into multiple lawsuits
is going to be eventually a big case
because the challenges were largely
thrown out by the courts
but the president and his followers
still refuse to concede
rallies on the streets and online
twitter
trying to fight on the side of fact
repeatedly flagging up the president's
own tweets as misleading
what we saw in these elections uh this
uh last year we we've seen election day
turn into election weeks and election
months uh the rules of the game were
changed throughout the united states due
to
coronavirus uh restrictions etc of
course
and so what you had is a record turnout
and tens of millions of people voting by
mail and so
basically what a lot of people think on
the right is that the the elections were
stolen
against president trump and that he was
the rightful winner so what you're
seeing is a backlash right now
the scenes in the u.s capitol are what
happens
when people can no longer agree on facts
many here
genuinely believe the election was
stolen they aren't going to change their
mind easily
debra haynes sky news
[Applause]
well i'm joined now by donald trump's
former aide omarosa manigault newman and
omarosa first of all like every american
watching those
those pictures uh today what was your
reaction to what you were seeing
in 20 years of being in politics i have
never seen
anything like this the first reaction
that i had is
when are there going to be any
reinforcements where is the security in
forces
where are the police and there were none
and as the moments went by
you saw it escalate so quickly to the
point where there was
one of the members of the mob sitting in
the speaker's seat
this is unacceptable
we heard what donald trump said what an
hour or so before
those protests began to to unwind uh
he he was encouraging his his supporters
to come here maybe not
encouraging violence direct directly but
what's in his mind at a time like this
when he knows there's so much anger
amongst his own supporters
as i've known him for the last 18 years
donald trump is bloodthirsty he wants to
see blood spilled in the streets of this
country
he wants the chaos he wants the violence
he wants the destruction of property
because he is upset
that he did not win this election that
he did not get us away
and that on january 20th he will no
longer be president of this country
we ask this question so often don't we
is is this the thing that makes him
change tack do you believe
that now what two weeks out from the
inauguration that what we're seeing here
would encourage him to to change
direction to take a different tone
in the message he sends to his
supporters donald's not going to change
at this point he is only going to
escalate his rhetoric
he is going to incite more violence and
as nightfall
begins to fall here in the united states
you're going to see much
more violence these protesters came
prepared to fight and that's what we're
witnessing right now
donald won't change in fact he would not
even allow the national guard to come in
and calm the situation
because this is exactly the same that he
wanted
we heard from from mitch mcconnell
unusually uh speaking out against the
president on on the senate floor before
all of this
happened are you surprised that
republicans like him
now appear to be sending a very
different message to the president than
they have for
the last weeks and months you know what
surprises me the most is that they
hadn't spoken up
prior to now i mean everyone knows that
donald trump was
trying to you know overturn the election
and
trying to get a result that just
wouldn't come and so i expected the
republicans would speak up for what was
right what was just
but they remained silent and so here we
are on the 6th of january
and mitch is just starting to speak up
and push back against donald trump
and the the falsehoods that he's been
espousing
and so it's a little too late right now
for that because
things have gotten out of hand
and do you fear for the the inauguration
two weeks today
well i'll be right there in the thick of
it and so as i watch these images
certainly
i'm nervous but this tradition will not
be stopped
by a mad mob of people who do not
believe that
donald trump lost and so i will be there
the rest of the country will be watching
and and hopefully there will not be this
type of violence
and if there is hopefully the response
will be better than what we saw today
omarosa manigault newman thanks very
much for your time tonight well more
from here in washington later but for
now
back to anna at sky news center
greg thanks very much indeed for that
well here boss johnson warned today that
any retreat from the lockdown will be
cautious
as the uk recorded its highest number of
covert deaths
since april there were 62
322 new cases recorded
in the uk and a further 1041 coronavized
deaths were confirmed
that brings the total number of people
who have died in the uk within 28 days
of a positive test
to 77 346 deaths
as of yesterday 1.3 million people have
so far been vaccinated
our deputy political editor sam coats
reports
the invisible enemy permeates all
aspects of our lives once again
the shops and streets